[Music]
it's easy to call to mind an array of
Disney Princesses and villains but what
about some of the most interesting
characters that never get their
well-deserved time in the spotlight wait
until number one to see why Nana from
Peter Pan is the most underrated Disney
character if this is your first time
visiting the channel don't forget to
subscribe to the things and please give
this video a big thumbs up here are 10
most underrated Disney characters Cronk
from Emperor's New Groove Kronk voiced
by Patrick Warburton is probably among
disease funniest villains ever Kronk is
yzma's henchman albeit not the most
effective his loyalty keeps him on track
delivering on the schemes he and yzma
concocts to overthrow their ruler Cusco
whom they effectively transformed into a
llama though Emperor's New Groove did
not receive a lot of attention when it
was released it has since become popular
and discussed often on tumblr Kronk is
such a memorable and relatable character
that he became the basis of the movie
sequel Kronk's New Groove so he
definitely deserves a spot on our list
of underrated characters
Meeko from Pocahontas Miko is the much
needed comic relief that Pocahontas
needs he is a loyal adorable hungry and
hilarious sidekick to Pocahontas who has
to struggle with coming to terms with
cultural restrictions in the face of
love Miko obediently follows Pocahontas
everywhere including diving down a
waterfall
he also repairs her necklace keeps flit
on track and effectively turns an enemy
into a friend Percy the Pug learns to
abandon some of his luxuries and
befriends the two sidekicks proving how
lovable Miko really is Miko's innocence
and curiosity is addicted to watch as he
still snacks from John Smith and even
performed CPR on flips penny from the
rescuers penny is an orphan who had been
kidnapped by the evil Medusa who forces
her to search for a diamond that is lost
in a pirate's caverns
however penny is not the helpless child
Medusa assumes her to be instead she's
extremely resourceful sending out
requests for health and bottles that
eventually get to the Bernard and Bianca
mice from the rescue Aid Society penny
has one of the best sidekicks a senior
cat known as Rufus who adores
gingersnaps and
jairs penny that someday she will be
rewarded with the perfect parents she
deserves penny doesn't just warrant
caring parents but recognition as a
resilient young character who refuses to
give up hope
quickly from Milan you'll remember
cookie as the lucky crook that gifted to
Milan from her grandma Fah crickey
brings a lot of light-hearted fun to the
screen with his talents that includes
shadow-puppet impersonations disguises
and quality finiman ship the small
sidekick follows Milan along with moo
shu as she disguises herself as a boy to
take her father's place in the war one
of cookies most underrated qualities is
his screen presence and humour despite
the fact that he never says a word
crickey proves that actions speak louder
than words and would be a valuable
friend and companion to anyone warrior
or not
jock from lady in the [ __ ] lady in the
[ __ ] may be most known for the romantic
cost of sharing scene between lady and
[ __ ] but fans tend to forget about
Jacque Jacque is the Scottish terrier
that can often be found alongside his
bloodhound companions trusting jocks are
thoughtful dog rooting for lady and
helping her any way you can he delivers
a truly heart-wrenching performance when
trusty is captured by the dog catcher
more than anything job proof that being
small in size does not mean being small
and personality and deserves a lot more
credit than against those jock is an
underrated character for sure
it's undeniable that many of the canine
characters from this Disney movie are
normally cast aside when discussing the
movie and deserve a lot more attention
than they get at the mode from The
Incredibles Edna is underrated for so
many reasons but her unique and
unforgettable qualities are hopefully
soon to be recognized in an anticipated
sequel The Incredibles - Edna mode is a
short statured assertive and creative
superhero costume designer known for her
focusing on the present and her refusal
to include a cape in The Incredibles
family costumes Edna is an unforgettable
character that is massively underrated
her inspiration explains much of her
quirkiness as she is meant to resemble
the work and personality of Hollywood
costume designer Edith Head had began
her career in the 1920s and was
extremely successful accumulating eight
Academy Awards for her designs
spays 'el from the Great Mouse Detective
despite its success as a box-office hit
the Great Mouse Detective is often the
movie left behind
when listing Disney animated film basil
and Dawson were inspired by Sherlock
Holmes and Watson albeit tailored to be
a more lovable Mouse duo as the to
venture to find Olivia's kidnapped
father not only are these two detectives
have blast to watch in the surprisingly
dark movie but basil and Radhika's the
movies villain share such an enticing
dynamic that contributes to the fact
that basil is such an underrated
character both had the ability of
getting under each other's skin causing
them to become obsessed with finding the
best way to outsmart the other basil
definitely has the audience backing him
as he and Dawson used their vast
detective skills
Terk from Tarzan Turk is the perfect
best friend of Tarzan making him feel at
home among his ape family he completely
embraces Tarzan despite his differences
like a true friend should and helps him
learn the ropes or should we say vines
Turek stands by Tarzan and is very quick
to protect him whenever the two run into
trouble we also have Turk to thank for
turning a campsite into an unforgettable
musical experience known as trashing the
camp Turks characteristics sassy
attitude as an adult was so difficult to
match that Rosie O'Donnel voiced both
child and adult Turk
Thomas O'Malley from the Aristocats
Thomas O'Malley is a stand-up cat even
though this character introduces himself
by singing a song named after him
getting to know a trio of kittens and
their classy mom Duchess has an
extremely humbling effect on him Thomas
O'Malley is the alley cat turned
gentleman starting off as a bad boy
audiences of all ages easily fall in
love with the characters mac for swingin
Tunes his entourage of alley cats and
his unrelenting desire to help Duchess
and her high-class kittens are exactly
what makes him such a dynamic underrated
character naina from Peter Pan windy and
the children's family dog naina is
perhaps one of the most impressive and
underrated characters in Disney history
this dog is somehow able to carry trays
recognized alphabetical order and makes
beds as if her extensive skills aren't
impressive enough not it demonstrates
her devotion to her family by trying to
fly away when Peter Pan takes Wendy John
and Michael to Neverland this dog goes
above and beyond and trying to take care
of the children despite the fact that
mr. darling kicks her out for the nights
proving that she is truly an underrated
character what are their Disney
characters
do you think are underrated and that's
all for the ten most underrated Disney
characters make sure to LIKE this video
and subscribe to the things to catch
more videos like this thanks for
watching
[Music]